I was thinking yesterday I had this
thought as Pearl does and the thought
was are women are we really that smart
and I was thinking we have all these IQ
tests right that tell us women are like
smarter or more mature than men and I'm
like is that what I see in real life and
I just started thinking I'm like
do I really see semen acting more
maturely
and then I mean men might get into a
crawl over something stupid but they
kind of work it out we're women it's
like we're petting to each other for
like a decade a literal decade it's like
you'll see sorority sisters that haven't
seen each other in years talking about
how
they like hate each other like 10 years
later I'm like is that really maturity